[Applause]
if you guys saw this news the rock
bought the xfl with his investors for 15
million
it sounds like nothing i don't know the
details of this but i think this is
potentially a genius acquisition
i agree but i don't know how it's going
to work out i have an idea
i have a theory the nfl
will not operate in the bubble for
whatever reason
maybe there's too many teams maybe
there's not enough facilities to
function that many games
maybe it's just too big maybe the teams
can't make enough money without the
revenue from the stadiums who knows
but it looks like they're not going to
operate in the bubble and
the sports that are not operating in the
bubble seem to have a lot of difficulty
stopping the coronavirus spread baseball
you're seeing people drop like flies
that's how much baseball sucks as god is
like shut this [ __ ] down even baseball
players like i'm opting out
yeah right like you barely have to opt
in to baseball you just sit around the
whole [ __ ] game
anyway i think the rock and his business
partner have an amazing opportunity
to eat up some real estate from the nfl
of the game of football because they can
operate in the bubble
if they do eight teams only think about
it that's
four games a week yep right eight teams
only four games a week matter of fact if
you want to bring it down to like
the bye week or whatever like that you
could even limit maybe more who knows i
don't know the exact math
but let's say four games you could do
you could easily do four games in one
stadium
if you have two stadiums you know some
of these places have like a practice
facility and the main stadium next to
each other
you could easily run that eight teams
bubble for football nfl shuts the season
down because
all the players keep catching corona and
they don't want to spread it anymore the
coaches are old and overweight the
amount of overweight
andy reid catches corona he's [ __ ]
dead well i mean even yeah just
overweight players all linemen are
overweight yeah but maybe they're in
such good shape
that's that's the only thing i thought
about but the coaches aren't yeah
coaches look like [ __ ] yeah closers are
the same weight just uh
just no yeah yeah yeah no one does
nothing so
i think they could eat up some real
estate for football and here's the thing
if they do the upside is hundreds of
millions yes if they don't the downside
is a few million 15 million and if
you're the rock your partial shareholder
with your business partner who's this
expert
let them take all the costs you're the
face of the brand
you're synonymous with wrestling in and
of itself you come out there
do some you know opening intros or
whatever it is this is the xfl
you do everything vince mcmahon couldn't
pull off yep
i think that they could make a lot of
money and if they don't
the risk was 15 million which sounds a
lot to the four of us and everybody
listening
but to the rock who's probably worth
half a billion dollars
yeah 15 million is worth the risk
the rock is like the most bankable star
in hollywood he's like the only star
that's never had a flop
was will smith now it's him yeah he he
i'm sure he was the producer on his
football show whatever the [ __ ] that was
playmakers whatever ballers i think he's
this to him is like
very low risk in terms of like three
million or whatever he's putting in and
very high reward
yeah so you take that risk great
business decision yes